the person who designed it did not
design well she did not think it through
it's michelle phan love muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD and obsessive
skincare ingredients checker today I'm
going through this skincare bracket that
I posted on Instagram you choose your
favorite ingredient out of each matchup
and then eventually you get to the
finals and you pick your favorite
ingredients I also polled my Instagram
followers for which ingredients they
liked and so we're going to go through
the popular vote today as well as my
personal bracket it's been really
interesting seeing different people's
brackets and what won for them if you
want to fill your own in I'm gonna put a
link in the description to my blog post
which has the empty bracket I would
recommend that you fill it in before you
watch this video so that you won't be
influenced by what's popular or what I
like if you like this sort of video give
it a thumbs up you can also subscribe to
my channel and click the notification
bell if you want to see more videos like
this so before we get to the results a
few things about the bracket so how I
pick the ingredients they were pretty
much just random ingredients that I
thought were popular or that I
personally really liked I probably could
have split it up into actives and
sunscreens and moisturizing ingredients
to make it a bit more fair but yeah it's
just fun another question I got a lot
worse why I didn't organize it by types
I have tretinoin vs. retinol versus add
a fleam in one corner and the reason is
because that was really hard they just
aren't the same number of ingredients in
each category and so organizing it just
didn't really make sense and so I
figured doing them randomly
eventually you're gonna get weird things
matching up against each other like in
the second round anyway so we may as
well just have it in the first round and
save my brain from frying so here is my
personal bracket first the first matchup
is glycerine versus caffeine in case you
didn't know I am obsessed with glycerine
there is a molecule of it here I have
really dehydration prone skin it is
pretty much a lifesaver it is the best
like 10-minute glow-up I can have so
that one
caffeine I've barely tried there are a
few caffeine products that I've been
meaning to try but I just haven't gotten
around to it I will try them very soon I
believe they might be good for your
under eye and my under eye does need a
bit of help
glycolic acid versus Kalin I do like a
GU kale and clay mask I have oily skins
that's really nice for soaking out the
oil
and my skin looks nice afterwards but
I'm really lazy so I end up doing a clay
mask every two months or so so I had to
give this one to glycolic acid glycolic
acid was my first alpha hydroxy acid
since then
I've branched out but I do have a soft
spot for it I do like it in a low
concentration toner I picked liquorice
over mineral oil licorice is good for
sensitive skin and it also helps with
hyperpigmentation and I am a
pigmentation monster so licorice had to
win I think chuckles really overrated
but maybe I haven't met the right
charcoal product I do have a video on
charcoal and how it works I just don't
think it really works that well on skin
like not not a lot better than like clay
or a scrub laughs he cast it on the
other hand it's like glycolic acid but
better it's a better human it's not
quite as strong so maybe it won't give
you as immediate results but for someone
like me who has pigmentation prone skin
lactic acid is probably a bit safer as
well so I think lactic for that so for
the rest of the top left bracket
glycerin 1-over glycolic acid for lactic
acid versus licorice I pick lactic acid
because alpha hydroxy acids I do love
chemical exfoliants and they're really
good for unclogging my pores so I picked
that so glycerin versus lefty gas that
this one was really really hard and I'm
still not entirely happy with my answer
I picked glycerin when I did it now I'm
sort of having second thoughts and
thinking I should have picked last agasa
because lactic acid is also a humectant
as well so it's kind of like humectant
plus exfoliant glycerin just a humectant
I don't know I picked glycerin so I'm
gonna have to live with that glycerin
one in that top-left quadrant
when I was running this poll a lot of
people messaged me and complained that I
was making them make really hard choices
and they couldn't choose but as you can
see I am also torturing myself I am
suffering with you we are in this
together all right the next bracket we
have regem Elvises aloe vera that was an
easy choice retinol definitely wins for
me aloe vera I think it's really
overrated just use glycerin everyone
just use glycerine glycerine is great
Treach in Olga's a shea butter I have
oily skin so butters and stuff don't
really do it for me so treasurer norm
wins and treasurenails doing great stuff
on my skin as well so I've got like lots
of like smaller pores around my cheeks
I pretty much have Paula's cheeks it's
really weird
I fix now over hyaluronic acid because
personally I found that Snell has done
more for me I've probably just
overlooked it a lot because it does tend
to be quite low down the ingredients
list and it's not always called out as a
star ingredient so maybe it is an
underdog which I should have picked but
I pick snail also I really like fitty so
I had to pick snail for her snail did
win her bracket
I picked zinc oxide over mandelic acid
because I kind of felt like I had enough
assets already which I realized is a
stupid way of thinking because it's not
how the bracket works but I fixed in
coxide because it is a nice sunscreen
ingredient that does everything and I
haven't tried that many mandelic acid
products that I've noticed doing
anything for my skin so I just pigs ink
so finishing off the bottom left bracket
retinal vessels retinol this was a
really easy choice for me threatenin all
the way threatenin is like retinol but
better in every way it is more
evidence-based it is directly active so
you don't have to worry about whether or
not it's getting converted properly in
your skin it is regulated as a
medication so that means it has all
these safety and efficacy checks in
place it in Australia at least is
subsidised because it's a medication and
so it is really cheap compared to
rational with snail vessel zinc oxide I
was pretty mad about zinc oxide sets now
one that and the snail versus tread
sorry fitty it's it's Trat Trat one top
right bracket as a lake acid versus a
bit benzo and I pick as a lake acid I do
think over benzene is underrated I think
it gets an unfair rap because it is
quite unstable but it does give really
high UVA protection when it's stable but
because there's so many great UVA
filters available in Australia for me I
just couldn't pick it so as a lake acid
is great the only problem with as oleic
acid is that I haven't really tried many
products that have a nice texture I
think because you need to use such a
high concentration of azelaic acid all
the products tend to be like a bit
chalky and dummy but hopefully I'll have
a few good recommendations soon because
I am trying out a lot more of them plant
oils versus salicylic acid I do like
plant oils I really like rose hip oil it
was one of my first skincare products
that I noticed gave me a massive
difference on my skin but salicylic acid
wins because I am
with tons of blackheads I need the
salicylic acid I also have the polis
Troy salicylic acid in a spray bottle
it's so good for bacne so because I have
this horribly damaged hair I have to use
a lot of hair conditioner and afterwards
it tends to clog my back so you can just
like hunch and hurt for gravity to do
its work and you just spray and it gets
on there and no clogged pores no bacne
amazing petrolatum versus benzoyl
peroxide I have a love-hate relationship
with benzoyl peroxide I know it works
great all of the studies say it works
great it does work great but the peeling
and the irritation it's just sometimes
not worth it for me I did also have this
one experience back when I was in second
year uni and I used 10% on my face
thinking I could dilute it to 2.5% it
doesn't really dilute that well I
probably just went over zealous and I
had a sunburn looking face for about a
week and everyone asked me if I was okay
so not the best memories associated with
pencil peroxide also it stains things
well the opposite it bleaches things and
yeah if you're already making my skin
super flaky don't destroy my other stuff
as well
bad benzoyl peroxide I think I also pick
petrolatum because it gets such a bad
rap from like natural brands and it just
shouldn't it's a really good ingredient
it's safe it does lots of things it's
effective
just let it live you can also light
fires with petrol ajam petrol Artemis
petroleum jelly by the way so you put it
in some cotton ball and then you light
it and burns really well and so it can
set the rest of your fire on fire
lifehack centella versus Matrixyl I just
put Matrixyl there as a general name for
the anti-aging family of peptides I
don't really use peptide products that
much I don't really see a big difference
in my skin and I think maybe it's just
because I don't have enough wrinkles yet
which is sort of like a humble brag I
guess I'm sorry sant ella i have used a
lot of products with centella I do
really like how well it heals my skin my
sister uses it a lot as well and so
centolla is our family love so I pick
some Intelli so salicylic acid one over
as a lake because I've got more
variance with it and I just really like
it petrol a lotta missus until I picked
petrolatum because I need lip balm
salicylic acid versus petrol Adam I pick
salicylic acid and so that one my top
right quadrant on to our final quadrant
ceramides versus niacinamide I picked
niacinamide ceramides are a bit tricky
because you need to have the right ratio
for them to work and you have different
ceramides and so generally it's just a
bit too hard to work out of a product as
good so nice and a mired it's more of a
no-brainer it's not an irritating
product so you can just dump it on your
skin and it should be fine it's really
good for sensitive skin and I send my it
sort of does everything it decreases
pigmentation it fixes your skin barrier
it protects from certain types of skin
cancer its anti-aging anti-wrinkle anti
cell onus there's also a study showing
that it reduces sebum it probably cooks
your dinner for you as well and gives
you a kiss before you go to work so nice
and made one but it definitely messes
tennis orb I've never actually tried it
definitely and it is a rationale it
that's particularly recommended for acne
it's in different Sochi nosov s1 because
it is my default UVA filter to nosov
versus nice and wide this was hard I
picked Janice or because nice and wide
it does sometimes give you a bit of a
red flush if it's not formulated
carefully so you know someone for that
vitamin C versus squalene I picked
vitamin C squalene it's a nice
moisturizer but I can replace it with a
million other moisturizers vitamin C I
need it for my pigmentation green tea
versus honey green tea has more Studies
on it I mean not that convinced by
either one but green tea does have
antioxidants it's more likely to work
vitamin C versus green tea easy choice
vitamin C one that 1 receiver sustain
yourself I picked vitamin C I guess it's
a bit weird because tennis or bass is
one specific UVA filter and vitamin C is
a group of ingredients so I think it's
just the person who designed it did not
design well she did not think it through
so onto our semi-finals we have glycerin
versus tretinoin and I picked glycerin I
disagree with Michele from three days
ago she was younger and not as wise I
would have picked retinol but I'm stuck
with glycerin I guess I think my
thinking
threatenin is easy to overdo and when
you overdo it it really hurts glycerin
you can't really overdo you can make
your skin super sticky but then you can
just wipe it off so I think in terms of
regret maybe maybe I filled this in
after a turn-on night on my skin hook
salicylic acid versus vitamin C this was
hard and again I think it might have
been the fact that vitamin C is just
annoying sometimes so it's really good
at fading pigmentation it does not
you're sidin and anti-aging things but
it's less essential I guess so salicylic
acid does also fade pigmentation not
quite as well on me but it can be used
for that so you can use it in salicylic
acid peels I think also vitamin C it's
unstable it's a bit of a pain to find a
good product
it also tans your skin sometimes it
decomposes to form one of the
ingredients in some of the newer sunless
Tanner's and so you end up with weird
metallic smelling skin and brown fingers
so salicylic acid is a lot more friendly
and that spray so good so the final
showdown was glycerin versus salicylic
acid and I picked glycerine glycerine
one I think my thinking was if I
couldn't use anything else ever again
salicylic acid would dry my skin out and
so glycerin I had to use that because
glycerin at least wouldn't hurt on to
the popular vote so I've put this on
here with the numbers the numbers are
the percentage of people who voted for
the winner I'm not gonna go through it
in as much detail as I did for my own
bracket because I've told about all the
ingredients before I'm gonna go through
some of the things that jumped out at me
and I'm gonna go through my
disappointment my intense disappointment
why did you not end up with the exact
same bracket as me your mileage may vary
but only within one percentage point of
mine so overall I think there was a big
actors bias and I also participated in
this bias I think we all just tend to
think that actors are like the Silver
Bullet the hard hitters all of our
skincare routines which they are a bit
but having a good cleanser moisturizer
and sunscreen are super important and I
feel like that really does about maybe
60 70 80 percent of the heavy lifting
for most routines and actives are just
like the bit on top that you add on top
to get your extra boost at the end if
you don't have a good sunscreen
moisturizer cleanse
routine going then your actors might
even make your skin worse because a lot
of them do you make your skin more
photosensitive what's a top left bracket
I am mostly in agreement with this
excess of my favorite glycerine got
knocked out in the second round it lost
to glycolic acid not by to much so a 62%
to glycolic acid but poor glycerine it's
okay I still love you you're my favorite
with some of these matchups I wonder if
things won because they were more common
so more people have tried it and so they
were more confident and voting for it so
for example glycolic acid versus lactic
acid a lot of people who have tried
lactic acid prefer it but glycolic won
and glycolic is in a lot more products
than lactic so it could just be that
sort of bias so I think this is why
retinol won over threatenin as well
which kaolin hurons is very upset about
and I am upset as well you've
disappointed us greatly but I think also
because threatenin is a prescription
early product then a lot less people
have access to it a lot less people have
tried it and so it's also a bit scarier
I guess so rational one with that round
I did also have a lot of people
messaging me I'll see moon what Matrixyl
was so I think again there is the thing
where we are going to vote for the
things that we've tried our final match
up with retinol versus niacinamide which
I think are two really great picks I'm
really happy to say that everything in
house semi-finals is reasonably well
researched and rational ended up winning
so I think we drew all love vitamin A
because it does so much its anti-aging
its anti acne and it's really
evidence-based although most of that
evidence is thanks to threatenin who got
kicked out I might remind you I think
also the finals was a little bit of
sensitive skin versus non sensitive skin
and so if your skin gets destroyed by
rationale you probably picked a nice
sinem I'd did you enjoy the bracket was
it easy for you to pick or was it
difficult did you agree with the opinion
poll should I do another bracket on a
different topic leave me a comment with
all of your thoughts if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up you can also
subscribe to my channel for more videos
like this you can also check me out on
instagram at lab moth and beauty science
and check out my blog as well for tons
and tons and tons of posts on lots and
lots of sciency nerdy things see you
next time